[Applause]
before I get to the questions that you
folks have asked the vote just came in
for GOP Oh for gops no five Dems yes
shut down starts at midnight okay
Andrew Sullivan why do you think it is
that Republican politicians in DC
support policies with which virtually
all of their constituents disagree like
like who well I guess they're thinking
about flake something like the dreamers
people support the dreams overwhelmingly
I mean they do support a lot of the
things that what I found interesting is
there you know the Republicans have not
I mean no one can be it's just it's a
question of human decency that people
have lived here for half their lives not
be taken to a country they don't even
recognize it there's something about
that that's just so disgusting it
violates the core meaning of this
country and so I haven't been to thank
God I haven't heard a lot of Republicans
actually going raaah out on that I mean
that some of their base may be wanting
that but the public the Senators have
not been saying that because they know
so maybe that gives Democrats a lot of
leverage on the other hand if that is
inhumane and you can get that stopped
then letting him build a wall for a year
and a half you're talking about it like
it's like it's not a giant thing it of
all the 1,900 miles of wall that I'll
just give him the wall so give it to him
and can save them okay what the
government down okay how can we make
sure that the restaurants we dinette are
treating their staff yeah how do you
know what's going on in the restaurant
you know we actually created an app it's
called the ROC national diners guide it
tells you which restaurants are varying
better on wages benefits and promotions
and I can tell you most of the chains
are not
have a zero-tolerance policy around
sexual harassment we call it a zero
tolerance policy for complaining about
sexual harassment because you speak up
and you get fired oh wow oh my god the
breast drop is there an app that would
tell me if the busboy has the flu yes
actually tell you if they have paid sick
days because 90% of these workers don't
have a single day to take off when
they're sick which means thirds of
restaurant workers work when they have
the flu yeah Michael Wolfe do you feel
like you had an advantage over
traditional media because it didn't
matter to you if you burned sources or
bridges with your reports on the White
House 100% absolutely totally I mean I'm
not that like dr. evil I'm not going
back I'm still maxed out I'd say from
the side though you look a little bit
like Professor Farnsworth from from
Futurama well I was thinking I would
look a little like you actually actually
we all looked a little oh Michael
alright yeah three baldies
I feel pretty good on my own on my own
boss birthday
Larry memoir do you think comedy shows
are at the front line of combating the
lies of the government because they can
say and do things that normal news shows
can't well that would be better if you
still had a show oh thank you that's the
truth
you know what Bill I always used to
answer this question differently but it
seems more and more it is you know I
mean there's no news person that's gonna
deliver you know the statement that you
just said you know there's I haven't
seen you on singing I'm sorry I don't
see you cut me out on shows where we
hear these things the way there's
agendas that happen on newscasts now
they're not presenting news they're
presenting agendas and you know CNN
everything's breaking news except actual
news right I mean it's you know and and
now they've they've done a thing where
they're in the business of media
criticism itself you know where CNN will
criticize Fox Fox for criticized CNN
aside what the [ __ ] are you guys doing
for Christ's sakes
you're not the news they're making
themselves the news and Jon Stewart you
you of course I call the father other
with politically correct Jon Stewart
Iraqi political correct correct yes and
and Jon Stewart people felt like they
could trust you guys cuz they felt like
you were telling the truth and I think
that's just grown now all right do you
think the supreme law do you think the
Supreme Court will finally put an end to
gerrymandering this year I mean that
could be huge that it would be South
Carolina right now all right what's
going on with I think there's there's
there's the Wisconsin Supreme Court's
right which is the key now this is the
cave this is the big one that the
supreme court is ruling on this year
it's you know it's you know looking in
other countries the way they do that
district this is crazy the idea that you
would let the actual interested parties
yeah you know and depending just on
musical chairs who happens to be in
active offenses determine your politics
you could just we have computers now you
know you can actually put into a
computer okay or put in the factor of
compactness and put in the factor of
diversity and I will put in the factor
of whatever this region will make it
closer
we'll make it make it more about so
there's a real battle and you can do all
that and have a new map in a few seconds
and yet we can't it's another like we
were talking about tipping one of those
things where America almost unique and
not in a good way you know one of the
only countries now to pull out of the
Paris Accords one of the only countries
left who hasn't had a woman president
and the high incarceration rates and one
of the only countries that has direct to
advertising for prescription drugs you
know all these things that make us oh I
know we're not a [ __ ] country but in
some ways when you look at lots of stats
like infant mortality and literacy you
know we're not in the top ten for
president right but I am gonna say the
common denominator and all those things
is that people have more freedom here
than they do elsewhere and and I know
you appreciate that means things gonna
be as great as it might be have a very
tightly controlled government country to
make sure everybody ends up the same way
it's just a it's a it's a reason we have
to have a wall to keep think we do have
to keep people from coming some people
build walls to keep but it should not
prevent as we're speaking up foreign
justices that happen in this free
society that's right because not
everybody's as free as everybody else
that's right we're gonna fix that this
year thank you everybody
we're off to a good start
[Applause]